nonstop that sounds familiar have i
talked to you before oh yeah yeah
yeah you're the andrew clavin guy
yeah yeah thanks for letting me
okay okay so how's it going i got
another question about uh trying to try
to
get this whole red pill thing figured
out trying to kind of grasp exactly what
the philosophy really encompasses here
but
one of the one of the break points i'm
having here is that i i still believe
that you know the the nuclear family
is like the foundation of civilization
and if we're if we if we know that women
aren't going to ever march on city hall
and have the the rules uh um
equalized so that we don't get through
it every time such that we have to
not get married and not be in
uh ltrs that could be construed as
married right how do we how do we
reconcile that if we if we know that if
we know the society where where uh
nuclear family doesn't exist
is is going to be problematic in that
you know kids are not going to be raised
probably not going to come to understand
the authority and and respect for
authority et cetera so how do we how do
we reconcile are we is our is ours
watch what watch what society does and
watch and watch what women do and watch
what all the sims do
um
look
i mean
since we're since we're on the topic of
you know
like female dating coaches if these
women really gave a [ __ ] about men like
if they really [ __ ] cared about you
know their success why aren't they
leading the charge going to parliament
and capitol hill and putting and and
putting on like red pill [ __ ] hats and
and having them change the legislation
so that it's friendly to a man they
don't give a [ __ ] they just want
attention they just want money so the
point that i'm making here non-stop is
that it is what it is man this is you
know the societal constructs that you
believe in the nuclear family that you
know we once thought was a thing
unless you live in mormon country
and
you're marrying a virgin that hasn't
been around the block that subscribes to
men you know the leadership like unless
you can find like one of these like
areas of the world sort of thing that
that still exists and still exist intact
but society is still trying to destroy
those things there's they're still
trying to break them down right
they're still trying to convince you
know women to be promiscuous they're tr
they're still trying to tell women get
as many abortions as you want they're
free
you know it's it's it's health care now
sort of thing so why fight that why not
just surrender to and be like all right
if that's the world that you want
cool
all right now listen i'm not saying that
you're not gonna find
a nice woman that's gonna appreciate you
and say hey look man i like your i like
your skills i like your competency i
like whatever you know your hobbies
happen to be you know let me go make you
a sandwich while you're fixing the
blades on the john deere riding mower or
whatever you see what i'm saying like
they're still out there but they're
fewer and farther between and you can't
you know bank on well i'm just waiting
for that one or that one perfect one or
she has to exist it's like that's just
the way the world's going man and the
world just happened to go in that
direction and it is what it is
so yeah so our philosophy then is just
to let it burn just let it burn if
they're going to play it this way i
wouldn't let them crash and burn i'm i'm
in the let it burn camp
i'm in the let it burn camp i'm not i'm
not here to save the west the west
doesn't give a [ __ ] about itself it
wants to implode on itself i don't see
i mean just look at our leaders in north
america we got justin trudeau in canada
and we got joe biden in the united
states that's who leads the west in
north america
that's that's what people voted for and
then people go well i didn't vote for
that or you know joe biden was never
voted in you know that was a big scam
blah blah blah well he's still the
president today
yeah all right
again i'm just trying to understand all
the tenants of the red pill philosophy
and that was the everybody
with that question yeah everybody has
their own
view of it
you know what i mean like everybody's
got like
even in the red pill like even in the
manual swamp there's all these [ __ ]
different pills white pill purple pill
blue pill green pill yellow pill like
they've got all these new pills now
right and it's like
that's that's the reality that they want
to construct around their own ego
investments because they invest like
there's there's guys that'll be like i'm
christian value you know nuclear family
sort of guy cool there's lots of guys on
twitter like that there's there's some
interesting guys on twitter that i
follow that i think are [ __ ] cool
right but their women are still
hypergamous and society is is still
going to try to convince their daughters
to be promiscuous and is still going to
try to better ties their sons can they
do something about it yeah they can
homeschool their kids yeah they can move
out in the country they can become
ranchers
you know yeah they can buy more guns you
know sort of thing but look man the vast
majority of society
to me is clearly heading in a certain
direction and i'm not here to save the
west i'm just here to tell you guys
what's going on i just point to the
facts that's all i do all right all
right well you cleared that up i
appreciate it man thank you all right
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you